that's it lovely great to have you in
the program
it's a it's an awful moment sitting on
days like this i do go back to getting
my own sys results many many years ago
how has it gone this year
well we uh firstly i want to say huge
congratulations to the students because
as you said in your introduction they
have
they've experienced a really tumultuous
couple of years and they've they've
really worked hard to get to where they
are at the moment uh so we've got exam
results that will be coming out later on
uh this morning um the the marking
process has gone according to plan the
exam process has gone according to plan
there'll be
uh i think
lots of students
uh perhaps even the majority of students
able to get into their first choice
institution um and so
you know we're feeling the plan that we
put in place has uh we believe worked
waiting for results of course but but
just in terms of the the broad outline
of those results i mean we are seeing uh
results coming down compared to who we
were last year significantly the so off
qual um we've been working very closely
with and the plan was always to get
those grades back to the kind of levels
that we were seeing before the pandemic
they were more generous and i think
that's legitimate but they were more
generous during the pandemic years it
was always the plan to get them back
that is going to be seen this year so
students might get
slightly lower grades than perhaps they
were expecting and that they were hoping
but as i say i think we should see the
you know
the majority of students get into the
institutions they want to i i suppose
the question and it's been a question
that's been posed by a number of people
is whether or not this kind of
educational cohort the class of 2022 was
the correct year in which to get grades
back in line with kind of pre-pandemic
levels they have not sat an exam
their studies have been completely
crucified thanks to the pandemic and
remote learning and and so on and we
know that across the country the impact
of covet
differs depending on depending on how
much money is floating around in an area
so just justify the decision to kind of
make this lot of students deal with it
rather than next year well
as you say
this this group of students had a really
tough time that's why i congratulate
them so much
um and we put adaptations in place so we
made sure that the exams were fair we
gave greater spacing between the exams
just in case students did contract covid
which put pressure on the marking bodies
but they've stepped up to
their responsibilities but but funnily
enough it was the students themselves
who are most vocal in their desire to
ensure that they had qualifications
which were fair but robust and taken
seriously by both by institutions and
employers and whether it be a levels or
the new t levels that are coming out
this year or other vocational training
that's what we've achieved but just to
return to the point about the disparity
i mean fft education data lab that
published in times educational
supplement earlier this year there is a
north side split when it comes to
education pupils in the northeast
missing 15.3 percent of lessons compared
to just 11.6 percent of lessons
lost in london when there is such a
marked and statistically significant
regional disparity why is it fair that
we treat all pupils this year in the
same version
well the
the thing that we have got to do is get
back to
school-based teaching and exam based
assessment
this year we've taken a step towards
normality we have still had mitigations
in place there were adaptations during
the exam and obviously we have injected
a lot of money into making sure there's
catch-up tuition which will probably
benefit the cohorts coming in
after this one to be fair but
nevertheless this is what the teaching
profession is what the students this is
what employers and institutions want
we've done it in a progressive and fair
way and i think today what we'll see is
a lot of students
getting into the institutions they want
to get into or into the apprenticeships
or into the jobs that they
are going to be moving into but let's we
will return to discussing i'm sure the
air level results once we've got once
we've got the data and we've had the
chance to go through it but could we
just talk just in general terms about
your approach to schools i mean pretty
clearly there are incredible financial
pressures on everyone at the moment but
particularly in the educational sector
we've seen teachers getting a much trump
much trumpeted pay rise five percent for
existing uh eight percent for new staff
but that money's coming out of existing
budgets we saw cpi getting to 10.1
yesterday
isn't this now the time to say that we
need to see a significant and serious
expansion of our schools budgets well
what we have seen is a very significant
expansion already
um it's worth remembering that in the uh
pupil spending is lower in real terms
than it was in 2010 yeah but what we
what we have uh seen through this
spending review period
is a seven billion pounds uplift into
this school's budget four billion of
that coming into this next academic year
we completely recognize we completely
recognize there are cost pressures uh on
schools uh the the
the the majority of schools budgets of
course is uh staff pay and the award
that the uh the school system received
was in recognition that there was going
to be an upturn in in teachers
the schools they're going to have to pay
for it's the schools they're going to
have to pay for the increased energy
increased energy bills i mean we've got
a situation where what two and five head
teachers at the moment are
are suggesting that they will be forced
to cut teaching staff in their schools
in order to make the budgets work so
again i ask you we know that there's
going to be an emergency budget come
september no matter whether it's liz
truster or rishi sunay what would you
need to see in that budget in terms of a
payroll in terms of a rise in the budget
for the for the dfe that would actually
balance all this out well as i say we've
we've we got a very good settlement
we've got a generous settlement the ifs
which holds the government to account
very robustly has said that they believe
that the pay rises are affordable within
the financials just about affordable but
they do also warn that next year looks
problematic yeah and and that's why
whoever wins uh has committed to have
an emergency budget and it wouldn't be
right for me to preempt that but we do
recognize that there are cost pressures
we do recognize uh that
school leadership is going to need to
make some um
really important
decisions about expenditure but as i say
we we had a good settlement during the
sr period and the ifs who as i say yeah
hold us to account very robustly has
said they believe that these are
affordable yeah and also pointing out
that next year is going to be rather
difficult the the problem is of course
that all of these costs are coming and
they're continue to increase as i say
we've got two and five head teachers
saying they're looking at looking at
cutting staff i just think that there
are people genuinely come questioning
the conservative party's commitment to
education there have been six education
secretaries since these a level a level
kids started secondary school justine
greening damien hines gavin williamson
the demons are highway michelle donald
blink and you love mister and of course
yourself only gavin williamson lasted
longer than two years in post
yeah reassure me what were the
conservatives committed to secondary
education when you go through education
secretary so
well i can't i mean i i can't uh uh be
held accountable for the duration of my
predecessors in their tenure but what we
can say is you know this badge the t
levels this is about the uh increased
commitment to really really good quality
vocational training we've seen uh as i
say that that good sr settlement we've
seen an increase in the pay of starting
teachers to attract the brightest and
the best
into an incredibly important uh
profession i've spoken with the heads of
the teaching unions the heads of
academies um to to you know to thank
them for the work that they've put in
over these really really tough times we
absolutely recognize that education
unlocks benefit not just for the
individuals but society as a whole yeah
how many schools have had have had the
covert compliance ventilation installed
so i don't have that figure uh off the
top of my head but the point is that
what we know we know that schools have
shown a remarkable amount of resilience
in adaptation school you know children
have been
possible it's not very many at all
children have been back at school uh
over the last over the last couple of
years we've seen that we can have
children in school being educated being
examined keeping them safe and healthy
that's what uh schools have already
shown themselves capable of doing and
you could i mean so you could have the
ventilation installed that was promised
months ago so the point was the point
we're saying is schools have
demonstrated that they can teach that
students can learn and they can do so
safely in a covered safe way
they've shown they're already able to do
that that's what we want and expect them
uh to do and you can you know and i know
uh you know you want to focus on this
particular element but the point i'm
saying is schools have shown that they
can
teach students safely with the
circumstances they currently got i'm
just wondering with schools you know
looking unable to pay their fuel bills
whether come the winter time we will
once again be asking schools to open
windows in lieu of ventilation units
that this government has promised
well as i said schools have already
demonstrated that they can safely teach
children within a covered environment
that you know we we've seen that happen
that is why students have been at school
which is great it's the best place for
them to learn indeed which is why they
have been able to
sit exams which is the best way of
assessing how much they've learned and
which is why today we are going to see
hundreds of thousands of happy students
getting into their first choice
institutions and plenty of others going
to great universities or apprenticeships
or employment using clearing or clearing
plus or the other
advice and assistance that the uh that's
available to them i'm sure the head
teachers union would if you can find an
answer to that question about how many
schools have had that have had covered
suitable ventilation installed but we
just talked a completely off topic well
off your brief i should say um we're
about to see another set of rail strikes
only one in five trains apparently uh
running today
the rmt making it pretty clear that
there needs to be a significant increase
in the offer uh
in the offer for their for their members
what is your view on on the frequency of
these strikes and indeed what they are
asking for well
we should remember that the uh the the
rail unions are there to look after
their members
uh and whether it's the current head of
the rail union or bob crow in the past
they've done that very effectively um
they've got a very very good salary
package they have incredibly good
ridiculously good terms and conditions
um and what they're doing through these
strikes is they are disadvantaging
people trying to get to work trying to
put food on the table trying to keep a
roof over their
roof over their heads um i think grant
chaps has made it uh absolutely clear
that uh these strikes are are unfair and
completely inappropriate and it's wrong
that people are held hostage um by the
unions uh in this way and i i do also
just want to quickly ask you about uh
liz trust and and her plans to cut tax i
mean we've we've talked already about
the ifs uh this morning and and how
diligent they can be i mean they've said
this about liz trust policies indeed of
mr sunac as well hard to square the
promises that both are making to cut
taxes over the medium term with the
absence of any specific measures to cut
public spending
it does feel
that the the tax policy which has been a
big big part of of liz trustee's
campaign isn't quite hitting the
economist in the way that it's hitting
the conservative party membership
well liz has made it absolutely clear
that this is about stimulating economic
growth you go the economy
you can take a a slightly smaller slice
of a
slightly bigger pie or hopefully a
significantly a bigger pie that's very
very well established
economic theory and frankly what we have
seen is growth in the uk economy not be
as vibrant as we would like that's what
liz is is pursuing is a growth strategy
and if you don't have a plan for growth
you don't have a plan for government is
the point i would make but ultimately
today um i'm here with my education
secretary hat on um and actually seeing
this group of young people uh getting
these results
moving forward into the world of work or
uh further and sorry higher education
these are the people that are going to
help fuel that economic growth and i
congratulate them enormously for the
hard work they've put in over the last
couple of years but with your cabinet
minister senior member of government hat
on can we just talk about the cost of
living crisis and
and again we saw yesterday cpi 10.1
probably up to 13 by the end of the year
incredible amounts of money being spent
already on our energy when you have a
director of off gem resigning from their
post because they feel that the
the ombudsman is incapable of managing
the situation there's a fundamental
problem with the way the market is
working isn't there
well what we what we are seeing globally
and
the inflation that we're seeing right
across europe across
america across the developed world
driven
in large part by russia's invasion of
ukraine is is is something as they
driven by an exceptional specifically
fit for purpose
well look um i i've not had a chance to
read the full statement of the uh of the
regulator i saw the headline that they
resigned but i i think unsurprisingly i
was focusing very very much on making
sure the education unless you had this
unless you had concerns about off-gen
before you read that headline i mean do
you have confidence in it but in its
ability to work as an organization well
i'm going to read properly the um the
the point that's made i've been i've
been focusing as have teachers as have
universities i've had as have off call
and new cass and you know everyone
involved in education on this incredibly
important point of view i've you know
rather have my blinkers on i have to
confess on this one because it is so
important we had a plan it seems that
plan is is working and
um once we get through the uh today and
next week when the gcse results have
come out i'll be able to focus more
broadly on the full spectrum of events
happening but at the moment my focus has
been on the young people mr lee great to
have you thanks for being with us